alors je vais commencer par vous
sollicitez un petit peu intelligence
artificielle
qu'est-ce que ça suscite chez vous tout
de suite est-ce que c'est l' angoisse
anxiogène à mort ou au contraire est-ce
que c'est l'excitation l'entousiasme qui
anxieux ici lever les mains qui est
enthousiaste alors on a beaucoup
d'enthousiaste vous allez me faciliter
la tâche parce que les sondages qu'est
ce qu'ils nous disent ils nous disent
que 6 français sur 10 ont peur de l'ia
et pense que ça ne va pas arranger leur
quotidien ils nous disent également que
huit français sur dix pensent que ça va
bouleverser la société
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
bouleversé la société toutes les
révolutions technologiques industrielles
numériques ont bouleversé la société en
mieux on vit beaucoup mieux qu'il ya
trois siècles on s'accorde alors
pourquoi yat-il ces temps où ce
caractère anxiogène quand on parle
d'intelligence artificielle
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de vous
apporter une réponse qui interroge
l'impact de l'intelligence artificielle
sur la halle aux sites sur la société
sous le prisme de la recherche de
l'équité et de la lutte contre les
pratiques discriminatoires
pour commencer on va revenir sur ce
qu'est l'intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un ensemble de techniques brand
des machines des programmes
informatiques un peu plus intelligent
pour leur permettre de prendre des
décisions à notre place pour ce faire on
va permettre à ces intelligences
artificielles de traiter analyse et une
grande quantité de données et grâce à
des algorithmes qui sont des
instructions et des règles pour faire
des calculs et pour arriver à une
décision est bien césar ces
intelligences artificielles ont pouvoir
prendre des décisions à notre place
et une fois que ça s'est lancé une fois
que l'ia est branché tout se passe en
complète autonomie sans intervention de
l'homme fantastique maintenant qui
paramètrent ces intelligences
artificielles et bien c'est nous les
humains est un humain c'est biaisé
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
chacun on a une vision du monde des
phénomènes qui nous entourent qui nous
est particulière qui est lié à notre
histoire à notre expérience à notre
culture on appelle ça des billets
parfois c'est une déviation de la pensée
logique qui nous amène à prendre des
décisions pas forcément rationnel il ya
des biais positif quand on dit qu'on a
une bonne intuition par exemple et puis
il ya des biais moins sympa par exemple
la croyance souvent inconscientes qui a
un sexe fort et un sexe faible
la méfiance la peur de l'étranger et ce
qui se passe c'est que lorsque vous avez
d'un côté l'intelligence artificielle et
de l'autre les humains qui vont venir
nourrir cette intelligence artificielle
et bien ils vont transmettre ces biais
de sociétés dans ces intelligences
artificielles dans les bases de données
utilisées dans les algorithmes et le
phénomène qui se passe c'est qu'on
reproduit ces biais de sociétés dans les
intelligences artificielles ce qui peut
être très anxiogène
c'est que c'est tout automatisé donc on
peut plus revenir en arrière et par là
même on accentue des préjugés des
billets et par là même des pratiques
discriminatoires
c'est ce que des peines certains films
de science fiction
je montrais un extrait on est en 2154 et
max notre héros vient de subir une
altercation avec des robots policiers
pas très commode qui lui demande de se
rendre auprès d'un officier du stis les
mois d'été
foutez vous attacher
non merci beaucoup par contre prenez des
risques d'un appui de personnalité
indique un risque de 78 3% de régression
vers d'anciens schémas comportementaux
des véhicules agression à main armée
rébellion lors de l'interpellation
alors qu'est ce qui se passe on a une
intelligence artificielle qui a été
programmé pour décider que si on a un
type de personnalité eh bien on est plus
propice à récidiver donc max n'a aucune
chance de s'en sortir qu'il soit
innocent ou non
fiction ou réalité réalité aux états
unis il ya des juges qui utilisent déjà
des algorithmes pour évaluer la
probabilité de personnes inculpées a
récidivé et tenez vous bien
ces algorithmes sur évalue le risque
pour les afro-américains et
sous-évaluent pour les blancs autre
exemple on va parler notre plateforme de
e-commerce préféré ou une forêt qui a
pas mal brûlé cet été il ya deux ans
cette plateforme a créé un algorithme
des de recrutement pour nourrir lui
envoyer la base de données de toutes les
personnes qui ont été recrutées pendant
dix ans parmi ces personnes une majorité
écrasante d'hommes
résultat la goryl appliquer un biais
statistiques et favoriser candidatures
masculines et pour finir on va parler
d'un chat bottes très très mignon qui
lui aussi a fait beaucoup parler de lui
il ya deux ans qui a été lâchée sur les
réseaux sociaux pour parler avec vous
adolescents aux jeunes et en l'espace de
huit heures voilà le type 2 des changes
qui pouvait avoir
ça se passe de commentaire
néanmoins est ce que tout ça c'est une
fatalité
est-ce qu'on est condamné à reproduire
le pire de l'humanité dans les
algorithmes et à accentuer des pratiques
discriminantes pourtant puni par la loi
non
et ce en quoi je crois c'est qu'on a en
fait une chance une opportunité
extraordinaire de lutter contre ces
pratiques discriminatoires
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle en
la mettant au service de l'équité dans
la société
reprenons alors on allait un peu vite on
à mon intelligence artificielle
on a nos humains avec leurs biais de
sociétés et puis nous avons les humains
maintenant au courant
vigilant qui vont nous aider à ne pas
reproduire les algorithmes des biais de
sociétés pardon dans les intelligences
artificielles et mieux on va utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle en tant que
super pouvoirs pour lutter contre en
fait ce qui est hyper intéressant avec
intelligence artificielle c'est que sans
savoir
on a créé un cheval de troie on a créé
un cheval de troie pour venir infiltrer
les imaginaires collectifs et les faire
progresser vers des comportements moins
discriminant alors comment faire
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle on
va pouvoir identifier ces biais de
sociétés dans les bases de données dans
les algorithmes existant et puis une
fois qu'on lise en est dingue identifier
eh ben on va les corriger
reprenons l'exemple du recrutement on
peut demander un algorithme d'aller
identifier des inégalités salariales
entre hommes et femmes et par conséquent
de proposer l'égalité salariale
encore mieux on peut demander à un
algorithme de favoriser les candidatures
féminines c'est un billet mais c'est un
bien volontaire pour répondre à des
objectifs de discrimination positive
et cerise sur le gâteau on peut
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle l'équité
algorithmique c'est à dire que à la
source au commencement lorsqu'on crée un
algorithme on impose le critère de non
discrimination dans cet algorithme là
alors pour arriver là il faut tout
d'abord réglementé assez des
recommandations
il faut maintenant des labels des
certifications
il faut un cadre juridique il faut un
cadre légal il faut outiller il nous
faut davantage d'outils dead à la
détection des billets dans les
algorithmes dans les bases de données
et puis il faut financer il faut
encourager la recherche pour avancer sur
cette notion d'équité algorithmique
c'est un sujet passionnant parce que
l'équité ça fait appel à l'éthique et
l'éthique c'est subjectif selon les
cultures et selon un système politique
donc ça va mobiliser une recherche
pluridisciplinaire c'est paco la science
technique c'est aussi les sciences
humaines l'économie et le droit à la
philosophie
et puis enfin mon préféré
il faut éduquer et former dans vos
entreprises
formez vous équipant d'intelligence
artificielle recrutés dans la diversité
aujourd'hui le profil type d'une
personne dans une équipe d'intelligence
d'intelligence artificielle
c'est un homme blanc parlons des femmes
seulement deux experts sur dix en
intelligence artificielle sont des
femmes seulement un chercheur sur dix en
intelligence artificielle est une femme
et combien de pourcentage de la société
représentant nous voilà à l'université
il faut des formations pour les
étudiants pour qu'ils apprennent à coder
les quitter et puis au lycée au collège
vos adolescents vos adolescente qui
veulent changer le monde qui veulent un
métier avec du sens eh ben on leur parle
d'intelligence artificielle
voilà un cheval de troie pour changer la
société et à vos plus jeunes enfants
initiés les aux codes dès leur plus
jeune âge je suis certaine qu'à des
ateliers de code dans votre quartier en
définitive ce soir j'aimerais que vous
rentriez chez vous autant excité
enthousiaste que je suis quant au
potentiel de l'intelligence artificielle
imaginez encore une société dans
laquelle ni le genre ni l'origine
ethnique ni la religion ou l'âge aurait
un impact sur votre accès et l'accès de
vos enfants de manière consciente ou
inconsciente à l'éducation à la santé
à la justice au travail j'aimerais que
vous repartiez confiant mais averti
qu'il en va de la responsabilité de tous
entreprises chercheurs et à utilisateurs
surtout à l'heure qu'il est où les
algorithmes sont en train d'innover
notre quotidien on peut changer des
mentalités
via on peut changer des mentalités
pendant des siècles et on peut changer
les mentalités en quelques secondes avec
une ligne de code
saisissons cette chance merci
[Applaudissements]